This is iPhone 7.
It makes all the things you do with your iPhone better, faster and more powerful.
Two new finishes, black and jet black, highlight its seamless design.
A new camera captures shots you never could before.
iPhone 7 Plus also features a telephoto camera.
The two cameras operate as one,...
...giving you two times optical zoom and high-quality imagery...
...when you zoom even farther.
It's also the first iPhone with a stereo speaker system,...
...delivering a powerful, immersive audio experience.
The enclosure has been entirely re-engineered...
...to make this the first water-resistant iPhone.
iPhone 7 makes the things you do most even better.
It's the best iPhone we've ever made.